für die nächsten zweieinhalb wochen von
kommenden dienstag bis einschließlich
sonntag dem 6 dezember wird es daher
einen zweiten locker und wie im frühling
geben
zusätzlich zu den aktuellen maßnahmen
gibt es daher folgende verschärfungen
erstens neben gastronomie und freizeit
betrieben wird auch der handel
geschlossen
ausgenommen bleibt selbstverständlich
die versorgung mit gütern des täglichen
bedarfs lebensmittelgeschäfte drogerien
post banken und apotheken bleiben
geöffnet
zweitens körpernahe dienstleistungen wie
friseure kosmetiker und viele andere
werden geschlossen
drittens pflicht schon stellen wie schon
die oberstufe auch auf fernunterricht
als of distance learning um sowohl in
den kindergärten als auch in den schulen
besteht aber selbstverständlich die
möglichkeit für betreuung für alle die
einen bedarf haben
viertens home office soll überall gelten
wo es möglich ist
und fünftens wie wir es auch aus dem
frühling schon kennen gelten die
ausgangs beschränkungen jetzt wieder den
ganzen tag das haus darf also nur aus
bestimmten gründen verlassen werden
erstens und beruflichen pflichten
nachzukommen zweitens um
grundbedürfnisse zu decken drittens um
andere zu unterstützen oder zu pflegen
und viertens um sich die beine zu
vertreten oder sport zu machen das sind
die vier gründe die wir alle glaube ich
noch aus dem frühen kennen meine
eindringliche bitte für die nächsten
wochen ist treffen sie niemanden jeder
sozialer kontakt ist einer zu viel
verbringen sie ihre freizeit
ausschließlich mit den menschen mit
denen sie auch in einem haushalt
gemeinsam
und wenn sie alle erleben dann
definieren sie eine person mit der sie
während des lockouts in persönlichen
kontakt bleiben mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bet schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren